foreign
next is Daniel in Phoenix Daniel how can
we help
hi there thanks for taking the call you
bet
um
credit questions about credit cards uh
so first of all
um my wife and I got on the baby steps
kind of dragged our feet did it our own
way but when we got on the baby steps we
paid off the debt pretty quick so we're
pretty much debt free we rent
but like I said debt free the one
question I would have about credit card
usage though is for my employer
um I routinely need to make purchases
I turn in the expense report and get it
reimbursed so I'm agriculture director
at a small private school
uh a lot of the stuff's just you know
odds and ends plumbing parts I could do
that with my debit card but occasionally
I do need to do some larger purchases
and we just don't have enough really
saved up to to do that right now so what
were your thoughts on a credit card
usage of that kind of situation I would
have a school maybe another plan of
attack I would have more planning on
their part yeah they need to pick that
stuff up and if they want to do it by
credit they need to give you a credit
card of theirs it's you don't need to be
carrying a personal credit card for this
it's not your responsibility and it's a
Temptation have you talked to them about
the situation
um only briefly I you know
some of the administrators and people do
have credit cards that the limit's
fairly low because they're usually just
doing things like
um you know buying lunch for the
students on on outings and things is
this a specific store that you're buying
from
uh I mean I got in with the Home Depot
Rewards program just yeah what they can
do is set up a corporate account with
Home Depot and that builds directly to
the school
um now the other thing is you know I'm
buying like greenhouses and things of
that nature
um you know it's like a five six
thousand dollar purchase this is a
legitimate yeah
it doesn't matter you keep coming up
with reasons why you need this credit
card
and I'm telling you it's the school if
they're reimbursing you then this is
this is silly for you to have to carry
this personally
have you thought about the risk
yeah that's one of the reasons what
happens if you buy a five thousand
dollar greenhouse and God forbid
something awful happened and this you
know some let's you know something crazy
happens and then you're stuck
yeah that's true yeah I know yeah what
we do here at Ramsey is if you are in
that kind of senior leadership you would
be issued a company debit card that you
would use for those purchases it
wouldn't be expected for Ken to take
that out of his checking account and
then get hopefully get reimbursed later
that's just bad business
so I'd have a conversation with them and
say listen I'm not comfortable with this
I don't have the money to make these big
purchases and I don't want to go into
debt for this so we have to figure out
another solution and either they make a
corporate account the bills straight to
them they issue you a debit card or they
give you the petty cash to go purchase
it in cash so there's options
okay got it probably sit down with my
business manager and talk about those
options then yes and and again you lead
with the fact that you don't feel
comfortable assuming personal risk
that's your language but can I be honest
with you Daniel I don't think that you
are leaning towards doing this I think
this makes mental sense to you but
you're like okay can you be honest with
us are you benefiting from the rewards
if you buy this five thousand dollar
Greenhouse
I do yes that's true but that's um I
realize how minimal that is so at one
percent cash back yeah well yeah I I
hope you take the advice I'm not
convinced you will but I'm not either
it's the right thing to do for your
financial future
no it totally makes sense I kind of
hadn't thought of it completely into the
wording that you guys were using so I
appreciate that yeah I mean honestly
we're not trying to be you know use
Scare Tactics but this really is risky
George yeah I don't like that and these
are Big purchases oh my word and to your
point you know if he's having to get you
know agricultural things there's local
supply companies that would set up you
know some type of purchase situation
with the with the school the school has
a bank account I know they are a
business it's a private I don't like it
I think it's laziness on the part of the
school yeah they're like okay go do it
we'll just figure it out we'll figure it
out send us the receipts yeah yeah I
don't like that at all yeah you can and
here's the deal talk about the
Temptation Factor right because of the
points and all of the other things
you're sitting in your house one night
and here comes the commercial and
whoever the latest celebrity is what's
in your world Jennifer Garner is that
who it is yeah Capital One she's always
there there's something there's always
something there where they're telling
you to get your miles double this reward
this reward that and uh the Temptation
is well I can put it on my card I'll get
a free vacation at the end of the year
right and so hey they're asking me to
buy all these supplies I'll keep doing
it no and if you're a business owner
please don't do that to your team it's
uncomfortable puts them at risk and I
don't want to work for someone like that
truthfully